Dividing both sides by 3 gives us x is greater than or equal to 4. Let's check
this on a number line. Here is what this inequality should look like on the
number line. The number line is thus divided into two regions. There's one
region over here on the left of values that x is not allowed to equal. And then
the region on the right of the number line, that's all the values that x is
allowed to equal take on. Let's pick one value from each, and see if they verify
our solution. First, I'll pick a value of x that should work in the original
inequality. Maybe, 6. 3 times 6 is equal to 18. And, yes, 18 is greater than or
equal to 12. So that works. Now let's check a value from the left side, the area
that's not shaded in. So when I plug in a value from over her to the original
inequality, I should not make this true. A value from over here should not
satisfy this. Let's pick 0. 3 times 0 is equal to 0, and 0 is not greater than
or equal to 12, so this also confirms our solution.